1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
art
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
salut à tous et bonne année 2014 et
bienvenue dans cette deuxième vidéo faq
où on va répondre à toutes vos questions
alors le papy grenier est en cours de
préparation au tournage montage
extérieur pour la prochaine fois et vu
qu'il ya eu les vacances de noël qui
l'ont empêché de travailler pendant deux
semaines vous nous excuserez ce coup-ci
de sortir un épisode un peu plus modeste
j'espère qu'il vous plaira quand même
mais ne vous inquiétez pas on reprend le
cours normal des épisodes dès la
prochaine fois avec en plus de plusieurs
gros jdg qui sont en préparation pour
cette année d'où vous est venu le nom de
joueur du grenier de là bas tu as peu
près là bas alors la bretagne content
d'y être
est-ce que canard mana une carte de
donneur d'organes elle perçoit chez moi
on aurait bien besoin d'un fois c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait tu dis que tu
as besoin fois et comme ces canards mal
ça fait foi de cada casse toi le
meilleur kebab de bretagne c'est quoi
leur réponse est évidente c'est le zozo
kebab zone kebab ses 80 tic de kebab
différents une myriade de sauce pour
tous les genres pour tous les goûts et
pour tous les coeurs pour les petits et
pour les grands
then came up c'est le carrefour culturel
et économique du nord de l'europe
mais c'est aussi un lieu d'accueil et de
convivialité où se côtoient en toute
simplicité modernité tradition et kebabs
tels feux d'artifice dans votre bouche
comme un 14 juillet en plein mois de
décembre deux hommes capables vous offre
l'occasion unique de déguster un opulent
kebab et vous transporte à travers un
océan de saveurs qui ravira votre palais
de fin gourmet le secret de son régime
une énorme chiasse seb
as tu déjà pensé à tout raser la barbe
or est une raison secrète de la garde et
on s'est juste simplement que j'aime la
garder quoi était super content et je
suis super content si je vous invite à
boire un coup à la maison à rennes vous
viendriez baal est ok d'accord
je vais d'abord finir la vidéo quand
même désolé quand est ce qu'on mange on
sait que c'est même le métal mais toi
qu'est coutu fred des marches militaires
prussienne génial crescendo
[Musique]
le
ici deux meilleurs j'aspire d'un film
qui n'est jamais sorti lequel serait-il
le film intouchables et touchable racing
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as l'impression que
parfois tes blagues sont de mauvais goût
jamais alors comment tu connaissais
raconte comment tu verras contre et on
s'est rencontrés c'était en 92 j'étais
menacé par des terroristes
corbier on lève quand même j'étais
vraiment méchant
[Musique]
rappel 1911 à y avoir un meurtre 911
c'est pas lisse est en france je tape
bien non parce que là vous avez moins de
dix secondes avant que ce mec vous
repère non parce qu'un type qui se
balade avec une pancarte avait marqué
joue écolo du titre dans une convention
de jeux vidéo ce mec là il est un sacré
problème c'est qui ce clown
je suis pas sûr
[ __ ] j'ai eu de migraine
[Musique]
c'était le bon temps c'est quoi ton jeu
vidéo préféré
écoutez moi je suis un grand fan de rpg
j'adore tous les genres de rpg 1 que ce
soit les trucs mon plus récent trimestre
a vraiment récent mais par exemple
j'adore la série lost kroll j'avais
adoré oblivion même si je comprenais
rien au système de dialogue enfin c'est
surtout au système de roue de dialogue
comprenez rien du tout je ne crois pas
je vais vous tuer
les mecs y changer d'humeur tout le
temps oui d'ailleurs puisque j'en suis à
oblivion il ya skyrim aussi évidemment
que j'ai pas fini parce qu'en fait j'ai
arrêté avant la fin parce que ça me
saoulait mon perso its en fait tout
était trop facile en fait mon perso il
était tellement leur bile et du coup ça
voulait plus rien dire j'enchaîné
l'équipe de dragons comme ça sans aucune
difficulté
c'est le 500e dragon que je bute à tel
point que un mot je me demandais chance
il pouvait pas faire une indigestion
dame de dragon les jrpg aussi
typiquement le genre pokémon d'ailleurs
je suis un super fan de ce jeu depuis
que j'ai vu le film mais attention là je
parle du vrai film serait celui où ils
sont sur l'idh là et que les pokémons
essaye de les bouffer
après dans un style de jeu complètement
différent j'aime beaucoup aussi par
exemple la série des assassin's creed
par exemple mes plats par contre je
pense que je vais vraiment attendre le
dernier de la série quand ça sera
vraiment dans l'ère moderne pour
l'acheter j'ai vraiment hâte d'escaladé
tous les building pour la vision aveugle
par contre il ya un détail c'est je me
demande vraiment comment ils vont
intégrer de manière logique dans le
scénario et les bottes de paille et les
joyaux de paille là pour sauter dedans
quand tu tombes des immeubles effectués
comment s'est passée la rencontre avec
les gens de neige bloque alors vous deux
vous faites des vidéos c'est ça
[Musique]
on essaie on fout je vous prie d'excuser
le masters il souffre d'un déplorable
excès de politisation de gauche
trotskiste exactement ces matières assia
joueur du grenier vous avez déjà été
familiarisés avec le concept de lutte
des classes non l'altermondialisme la
critique du libéralisme et ce bastien
raciale je ne peux pas croire vous ne
soyez pas familiarisés avec le concept
de révolution permanente moi j'amène des
youtuber et vous amener un communiste on
n'arrive pas à baba
lalala lalala lalala
à est ce que c'est parce que tu n'as
plus d'idées que tu fais une seconde
vidéo faq pas du tout c'est parce qu'on
a la flemme
parce que toi ou c'est le jouer d'un
instrument de musique une petite démo
pour nos petites oreilles
[Musique]
le monde n'était pas prêt avec l ap
réapparaît je suppose fils me tue plein
de points d'interrogation donc baisser
avec cette caméra
évidemment je vais essayer de vous la
montrer pour que vous puissiez voir à
temps j'arrive pas je n'arrive pas je
n'arrive pas je peux pas vous la
retraire xbox one ps4 ou who
alors personnellement je n'ai aucune de
ces consoles parce que simplement je
trouve que ça sert à rien de les acheter
daiwa n'y a aucun jeu qui vaille la
peine d'être joué pour l'instant et est
son plein de bugs de merde
donc je pense qu'il vaut mieux attendre
les versions ultérieures pour les
acheter je pense qu'elles seront bien
plus stable savoir plus la fed par
contre un truc j'ai vraiment trouvé
complètement ouf ça envoyant une vidéo
sur le net tu es un mec qui se prend une
faute technique dans sa partie sur nba
2014 parce qu'il a insulté le jeu en
temps réel tels le mec il s'est
carrément espionné par sa console quoi
c'est vachement inquiétant pour la suite
mor lô l'avait fait chier ce concert des
fêtes vos greniers
vous essayez de le débrancher grenier ne
touchez pas à mon câble hdmi
je sais que j'ai commis quelques erreurs
mais il va y avoir gears of war bientôt
j'ai peur grenier je peux le sentir
je peux imaginer que tu puisses être
entendu et compris par ta console et
qu'elles puissent réagir en fonction de
ce que tu dis en vrai c'est juste fou
qui ont vu le concept de l'émission gdg
je te dis pas si on avait eu ça sur les
jeux rétro doit au plombier de merde
à quand un making-of officielle du jdg
bien bientôt on est en train de le
préparer d'ailleurs en attendant voici
le trailer officiel du making of est le
test le montage des effets spéciaux mais
en fait tout ça c'est risqué mais quand
on bosse sur youtube faut pas avoir peur
de mourir
et vous connaissez des missions joueur
du grenier des comptes a fait avec toi
[Musique]
mais vous faites du rétro gaming c'est
ça
c'est plus compliqué que ça
parlons maintenant j'ai entendus me
retire votre casque
claude 1.71 responsabilité le cadre
primum a plus d'eau
la vidéo va sortir en retard
ouais en fait toujours les choses en
grand
y aura-t-il un bêtisier oui on est
d'ailleurs en train de le préparer
d'ailleurs voici quelques extraits et là
donc je veux baup ou alors être plus à
parler et c'est pour ça que je joue la
sueur c'est vraiment le pire jeu de tous
les parias la boue on va la refaire là
parce que la chemise est là lambert et
c'est pour ça je vous assure vraiment ce
jeu c'est le pire jeu de tous les temps
sera pas non plus celle là c'est toi qui
à l'envers je suis court terme de
sérieusement vous avez vu les graphismes
de ce jeu franchement
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on se marre pendant les
tournages et voilà c'est terminé pour
cette petite vidéo faq j'espère que vous
vous poser moins de questions maintenant
en tout cas si vous en avez n'hésitez
pas on sera toujours là pour y répondre
et histoire de terminer en musique on
vous met un petit bêtisier de l'année
bisous montre fier de vos créations
[Musique]
ça va au rang des passions en compassion
[Rires]
[Musique]
il ya mille fois pire que ça y est la
famine et non pas google le stagiaire ta
gueule ta gueule le chat wac les risques
de famine en afrique
wax l'arist écoute ça l'atelier du pas
si mal
bon tu joue à des jeux pour y aura lyon
alors au monde à la bodega et fat man
c'est l'identité secrète de francs soit
[Musique]
ça se voit que tu as a débouché
on y avons dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]